overall context of what we're doing
every day we go through the daily
updates but again this it's important
that people see and understand the
overall context of what is going on what
is all this about what the United States
is doing what they're talking about in
Washington what we're talking about here
slow the spread of the virus to a rate
that the health care system can manage
slow the spread of the virus to a rate
that the health care system can manage
you are not going to stop people from
being infected there are all sorts of
percentages about what percent of the
population will be affected 40% 50% 60%
you will not be able to control that
nobody thinks you can but you can make
efforts to slow the spread because the
real question here is can your health
care system manage the influx of
patients that's all this is about and
China South Korea Italy it's the same
lesson over and over and over again you
get into trouble when the health care
system can't manage that rate of intake
so try to slow the spread so it equals
your capacity in the healthcare system
what do you do to slow the spread
test test test test we've made great
progress on testing the president's
agreement to allow New York State to do
its own testing is very important we
need more federal assistance in allowing
what's called automated testing which
the FDA still controls Roche is a
company that does automated testing the
president made announced an announcement
with them but it can't just be a couple
of companies for the United States of
America doing automated testing we need
more automated testing what does that
mean automated testing manual you put
the test tube in the
automated everything is robotics it goes
from 30 tests per day to 1000 tests per
day for a laboratory that can go from
manual to automated so that is a
tremendous difference and we need more
help on that how else do you slow the
spread density control this awkward
seating arrangement that we have here
today reflects two things number one
that the LCA doesn't work on Sundays
number two spacing out the seating
reduce the density so reduce the density
the best you can
those are both slow the spread
strategies okay what does it mean to
slow the spread this is doctor foul a
great new yorker by the way you see
everyone in washington looking at the
charts of the curve the curve flatten
the curve flatten the curve reduce the
rate so the high point of cases is
reduced so it can be managed by the
health care system that's what they're
talking about flatten the curve flatten
the curve why do you want to flatten the
curve because the curve is not a curve
the curve is a wave and the wave could
break on the hospital system that's what
they're talking about when they're
talking about the curve if you have too
high a number of people sick at the same
time when they descend on the hospital
system you will overwhelm the hospital
system that's the issue here it has
always been the issue here
overwhelming the capacity of the
hospital system
and that my friends is important you
know we you listen to the cable news all
day well why didn't we start testing
earlier why were we more prepared that's
all about yesterday right
that's all recriminations that's blame
we should have done this we should have
done that we should have done this I'm a
governor I am here today I'm focused on
what I need today to prepare for
tomorrow and that's what everybody
should be focused on you want to do a
retrospective on who should have done
what when and who's to blame put a pin
in pin in it and do it afterwards let's
be constructive which is focusing on
today and tomorrow there's no military
expression that management officials use
don't fight the last war this is not
about what happened yesterday we are
looking at a new war that no one has
seen before this is a case of first
impression for this nation we have never
fought a virus like this with this
potential consequence so plan forward
plan forward you see that wave try to
reduce the size of the wave assume you
can't reduce the size of the wave and
assume the wave breaks at a higher level
than the hospital system can accommodate
I believe that's what's going to happen
so what do you do New York State
Hospital capacity 53,000 beds three
thousand ICU beds is that a lot of beds
is that little beds three thousand ICU
beds presently about 80 percent occupied
okay so that means you have several
hundred ICU beds available why are the
ICU beds of a important because the
people who come in vulnerable
populations older people underlying
illnesses respiratory problems they need
the ICU bed they need the ventilators
they need the machines that breathe for
them those are the ventilators they are
in ICU beds the overwhelming crush is
going to be on the ICU beds not the
53,000 normal hospital beds because
those are basically going to be people
recovering from the flu you can recover
from the flu at home if it's really bad
you go into the hospital they make sure
that you are not dehydrated but the
critical people are the people who had
underlying illnesses and need those ICU
beds and those ventilators 3,000 goes
very very quickly on any projection of
these numbers what do we do maximize
existing hospital beds and hospital
capacity potentially build more capacity
again we're only talking about several
weeks here before that wave breaks
potentially build more on the existing
hospitals provide more staff identify
backup staff that's why we're going to
medical facility medical schools retired
nurses retired doctors develop a reserve
staff because health care workers will
get sick
and when they get sick they go home you
want to limit the hospital's limit staff
that's the way you limit the hospitals
find doctors who are on reserve and
purchase the necessary equipment
what makes an ICU bed and ICU bed
primarily the ventilator these
ventilators are expensive to begin with
and they are scarce and you can't find
available ventilators no matter how much
you're willing to pay right now because
there's literally been a global run on
ventilators and free up beds that are in
the hospitals how do you do that two
ways one we may get to a point where you
cancel all elective surgery you can have
your hip replaced next month not now or
develop it another facility that you can
move people from an existing hospital
bed who don't need intensive care into a
different facility how can you build
more Hospital capacity now that's a
great question it has never been done
before it takes years to build a
hospital it takes years to convert an
existing facility into a hospital it's
billions of dollars it's a work force in
the thousands but on the theory of try
everything an area that we have to
explore is can you build more Hospital
capacity now I'll get back to that in a
minute
on the reducing density slowed the
spread by reduced density I've been
talking to private businesses all across
this state I am asking them to
aggressively consider work from home
strategies I'm asking them to
aggressively consider
voluntary closings to help reduce
density as a social responsibility to
protect their workforce but I want
private businesses to aggressively
consider work from home in voluntary
closings depending on what businesses do
on a voluntary basis we could consider
mandatory actions later on we've already
taken mandatory actions no large
gatherings over five hundred fifty
percent of legal occupancy of a facility
that is a mandatory way to reduce
density in the workplace I'm asking them
today to voluntarily consider closings
and reductions in workforce if need be
we can calibrate up the mandatory
requirements that I have already put in
in action how do you calibrate it up
rather than 50% of occupancy it could be
40 percent of occupancy or 30 percent of
occupancy etc I'm not doing that at this
point but I am asking businesses to
aggressively consider these measures if
the private sector does not respond
voluntarily if the spread does not slow
then I would increase the mandatory
guidelines for New York State government
lead by example lead by example all
non-essential personnel in the state are
asked to stay at home from Rockland
County south that's about half the
workforce of this state in that area why
Rockland County South that is the area
of highest density of the number of
cases remember again
the number of cases varies widely across
the state you're calibrating your
actions to the data to the size
you should be doing different things in
New York City then you're doing in a
County upstate that only has one or two
cases right this is a calibration by
science to the facts the New York state
court system congregates many people
tens of thousands of people all across
the state I spoke to the chief judge I
asked her to come up with a plan that
keeps the essential services operational
criminal justice services emergency
Family Services etc the essential
services available but non-essential
services actions that can be postponed
to postpone them again reduce the
density coming into the court system I'm
asking private businesses to stay home
reduce the density coming into the court
system don't jeopardize the criminal
justice system don't jeopardize safety
don't jeopardize family integrity but if
it's non-essential then postpone it and
then come up with a plan that reduces
the courts to follow that concern the
chief judge is a total pro she is not
just a great jurist she's also a great
manager she's managed large operations
before and all of her skill and tenure
has been on display here as the chief
judge and as she's I ideally suited to
do this I asked her to come up with a
plan tomorrow that she will announce on
the specifics of how she'll implement
this how else do you reduce density come
to the issue of schools she reopened
schools closed schools a number of
schools have closed we've added Jim
Millar s you will remember Jim Morris
he used to work here he then
semi-retired went to academia he doesn't
consider it semi-retirement but I like
to work in that way close the schools
it's not that easy it's not that simple
close the schools for many families the
school is childcare if the student if
they you close the schools and the
children are home a large percentage of
the workforce may say I have to stay
home and take care of my children there
are school districts that are in
wealthier parts of the state where the
family is in a position where one parent
stays home or where they can hire a
caregiver to stay at home but then
there's everybody else right
I'm from Queens Queens New York I grew
up in a very working-class neighborhood
there most families don't have a
caregiver at home if the children stay
home one of the parents have to stay
home if there's only one parent in the
house that parent has to stay home yeah
but we have essential workers who need
to go to work
police people fire officers health care
workers again because we said this is
all about the capacity of the healthcare
system we can't have 1199 health care
workers not coming to work because they
have to stay home we can't have nurses
staying home because they have to stay
home and watch their child so it sounds
simple it's not simple you close the
school how do you feed the children for
many children the breakfast and the
lunch are the two main meals they get
and they get that at the school how do
you distribute food to all these
children who are now not in school so
those are very real concern
if you can address those concerns
address the negatives of closing the
schools then yes closing schools why
because it's totally in line with our
density reduction etc these concerns can
be addressed and it's up to the locality
to come up with a plan to do it we're
speaking to Nassau Suffolk and
Westchester County Executive Laura
Curran County Executive Steve belong
Suffolk County Executive George Latimer
in Westchester they're interested in
closing schools we said closing schools
if you can you can reduce the negative
childcare etc
student meals then I think it's a good
strategy but we have to address those
two negatives the worst negative is if
we lose essential workers police
officers say I can't come to work
firefighters say I can't come to work
public transportation operators say I
can't come to work and most dramatic
impact hospital workers because remember
the hospital workers there will be
hospital workers who get sick that's
going to happen that will reduce
staffing in hospitals that has to be
factored in because you know that's
going to happen so given that you want
to make sure you're not artificially
making that problem worse gemologist is
going to be working with these counties
to try to put together these situations
that would take care of the the negative
consequences of closing schools which
would then facilitate the closing of
schools ongoing operations just so we
sum up we're doing testing we've made
great progress
there Thank You vice president pence
Thank You president Trump we have more
to do density reduction which is what
we've been talking about school closures
and taking care of the negative
consequences that might happen is an
ongoing function hospital capacity
hospital capacity hospital capacity and
tracking of the cases mapping of the
cases identifying the clusters so we
deploy our resources the numbers today
total tested is up to five thousand two
hundred and seventy two as I've said
every day the more you test the more
positives you will find new cases for
forty two I'm sorry newly tested for
forty two this is just testing data
fifty two hundred tested four hundred
and forty-two tested since last evening
is that correct so you see how fat we
were only doing two hundred tests per
day we know did four hundred and
forty-two since last evening at about
six o'clock when we did the last
briefing positive cases 729 new cases 69
New York is the state that has the most
number of cases again you would have to
correlate that to how many tests the
other states are doing because the more
tests they're doing the more cases they
will find we've had three deaths we had
an additional death since we spoke last
seventy nine year old woman who had
multiple major underlying health issues
and had the corona virus and succumb to
the corona virus corrode
hospitalizations from 137 out of 729
that
19% of the cases this number relates
back to hospital capacity 65 patients in
ICU already this is against the number
of beds available and ICU units and you
can see how quickly these numbers move
46 patients intubated again perspective
perspective because we're fighting the
virus we're fighting fear the fear is
winning and the fear is disconnected
from the facts fear is an emotion
emotion can often be disconnected from
facts and that's what's happening here
but this tracks all the cases that have
been have happened since China one
hundred and fifty six thousand cases
five thousand deaths you look at the
people who have passed away in the state
of New York the three people those are
people who may very well have passed
away from contracting the flu right
every year tens of thousands of people
die from the flu we say they died from
the flu but they very often had they
were battling cancer
they had heart disease they had
emphysema and then the flu on top of
that underlying condition was the straw
that broke the camel's back I did an
open letter to President Trump today
that made three points it says we know
what is going to happen because we have
the data and the projection look at
China look at South Korea look at Italy
and just plot the numbers you know the
curve you know how effective you are at
flattening the
and we are now looking at a wave and we
know it is a wave do everything you can
to reduce the wave we are it's still a
wave it is going to be a wave and it is
going to be a wave that at any of these
projections will overwhelm the
healthcare system I asked three things
one on the testing that and I'm grateful
that he approved the New York testing
capacity FDA has to get out of the way
on the automated testing capacity
let us approve automated testing
companies it can't be one or two
companies of the only companies in the
United States doing this you need
hundreds of thousands accelerate the
testing second the federal government
has to provide help and guidance to
States on what to do and when to do it
this can't be a national policy of every
state does its own thing you can't have
a patchwork quilt of policies New York
State closes stores okay New Jersey
doesn't what did I do
I just sent thousands of vehicles over
the New Jersey flooding New Jersey
stores New Jersey closes stores and I
don't what did they do they just sent
thousands of New Jersey people to shop
in New York and then go back to New
Jersey you cannot do this ad hoc one
state at a time make a decision tell the
states this is the decision and then
let's go closing schools if you think
schools have to be closed well then help
us where do we get the child care where
do we get the meals
where do we get the money to provide the
meals there are ways to do it we could
just increase what's called the SNAP
program the food assistance program to a
family and say you know what your your
food assistance payment is going to go
50% you buy Johnny
breakfast and lunch but we have the
federal government that is integrally
involved in that help us plan and help
us coordinate and don't pit one state
against the other inadvertently by
having them come up with different
policies that's the second point the
third point is this you're going to need
more Hope hospital capacity you're going
to need more facilities you're going to
need ways to free up those 53,000 beds
you're going to need to construct or
retrofit physical buildings acquire
thousands of pieces of equipment like
this the state can't do that I don't
have that work force I don't have the
resources but even if I had the
resources I don't have the physical
capacity to turn SUNY dorms into
hospitals in three weeks I can't there's
only one workforce that can do that it's
the Army Corps of engineer engineers and
the military assets that's what they do
they build bridges they build camps they
have tens of thousands of personnel
trucks equipment excavators logistical
managers purchasing power use them to
come in right now identify existing
facilities that can be retrofitted
and use them to do it China built dozens
of hospitals in literally like a month
how the Chinese government came in and
said we're going to do this we're going
to nationalize it South Korea the same
thing you can't leave it to the states I
can't do it I do not have the resources
or the capacity and by the way I'm an
aggressive governor I push very hard but
there's no way that we could manage this
undertaking the Army Corps of Engineers
I used to be in the federal government
I've worked with them they're amazing
the capacity is amazing and what better
time to use those resources than saying
let's get to work
let's retrofit buildings let's purchase
the equipment yes let's use that massive
logistical machine of the military to
actually save lives it makes all the
sense in the world and by the way we
have no option we have no options
you know what management is pick the
best option my expression to my
colleagues what are my options well you
have none there's only one okay I picked
that option you have no other option
otherwise we will be sitting here nine
weeks ten weeks 14 weeks from today
seeing a healthcare system overrun we
will be saying we knew this was going to
happen
why didn't we provide more health care
facilities why didn't we do everything
we could to make that a reality doing
everything you can to make that a
reality means bringing in
army corps of engineer and that military
expertise and I hope the president takes
me up on it with that questions comments
any points I left out to my colleagues
here thing that we're starting
tomorrow's the DMV is gonna be moving to
appointment only so that we keep crowds
out of the DMV you can do that online or
if you don't have access online you can
go to the DMV make an appointment and
then come back government is an
essential operation to manage this
situation to me that's like saying in a
war when people might get killed at war
does it make sense to send soldiers this
is now there's know a couple of weeks
here there's know a couple of weeks
[Music]
look you should the Congress not show up
should the military not show up should
the police officers not show up you're
asking nurses to show up and do their
duty you're asking nurses at these
drive-through testing facilities like a
New Rochelle show up and do your duty
which is to help the public health and
put on a hazmat suit and take blood if
we can ask nurses to put on a hazmat
suit and take blood we can ask elected
officials to come sit at a desk and vote
on a piece of legislation they should
take all the precautions but Bernadette
I need them to authorize the laws and
the measures that we may need to do this
you need soldiers to fight the war
government must function because
government is doing all of this
government goes home none of this
happens down there well when you see New
York City shut that are you talking
schools businesses or streets there are
gradations Jesse the we started closing
down a few will businesses with our 500
gatherings and 50% of occupancy that is
closing down businesses gathering places
etc so we have started that
were full restaurants were full people
weren't abiding by the reduction but
then they're violating the law if
they're doing that and then the NYPD
should come in and shut them down right
now if your question is should we get
more aggressive in the shutdowns that's
something we're looking at and you look
at those numbers every day and there's a
knob and you turn the knob higher or
lower depending on what you see if and
I've heard what you've heard if people
are not enforcing the law or if the
numbers are continuing at a rate then
yes I will get more aggressive on the
mandatory regulations I'm asking them
today voluntarily closed down
voluntarily close down your bar your
restaurant your gymnasium let's see what
they do if nobody does it then we can
take more actions by the way at one one
point people actually react reasonably
and responsibly and people say you know
what I'm not going to go into a bar with
a hundred other people bumping up
against me because it's too high a risk
to have a martini I can have a martini
at home I want them to do their job I
want them to know I want them to do
their job I want the US Congress to sit
in there and do their job I want I hear
you I want the judges to sit in there
and do their job I want my team to do
what I'm doing which is sit in here and
do my job
conk this is why you are in government
this is what you're here if you didn't
want to be here you shouldn't have run
for office you shouldn't have a life
that been
you shouldn't have soared out of public
service job if you didn't want to fight
the war you shouldn't have enlisted in
the military okay if you didn't want to
do a public service at a time when you
have a social crisis then you shouldn't
be here you made a mistake in career if
you didn't want to help six people sick
people you shouldn't be a nurse right if
you wanted to stay away from alcohol you
shouldn't have been a bartender this him
that's the essence of what we do this is
the essence of what we do there is no
higher more necessary pure reform of
public service then what we're doing
right now this is it do your job later
people I'm offering them the same
guidance I'm offering everyone social
distancing be smart your elected
officials be smart like a business owner
like my kids like my neighbors like
everyone
should should should these state workers
the emergency mission nurses be putting
their health at risk should doctors be
putting the health health at risk should
Oh G s employees be putting their health
at risk it's not like they're working in
a hospital or taking blood they're
working in a State Capitol reading paper
and passing bills dispersing back to
their communities doesn't that seem to
be like the very definition of how you
spray in a bigger room
look you bring the US combat Theory
Jessie no US Congress no US Senate no
military operation and you shut down
everything no New York Times
[Music]
no no it's April 1 is the deadline I've
not thought about that I don't know if
it's legally a possibility why are we so
worried I know the self-interest here
because they're in this building I get
it but everybody is going through this
everywhere they're not doing a high-risk
occupation right well politics today
could be considered a high-risk
occupation but yes they could come here
do administrative work we're having
people the reason I have difficulty with
this concept I mean I'm having people go
into hospital emergency room
I have people going to people's homes to
take blood from people who believe
they're positive compared to what we're
asking people to do in public service I
mean this is not even in the same
category we're closing in to visitors
yeah you have two corporate executives
in every office building who are sick
you've had hundreds of people have been
walking into the New York Post for four
weeks your people in the New York Post
who are positive I mean otherwise you
just shut down everything and take a
deep breath people are going to get sick
many many many people will get the virus
40% of the population 50% of the
population 60% of the population
80% of will self resolved we're talking
about that vulnerable population senior
citizens immune compromised underlying
illness like the people who've passed
away so far like people who pass away
from the flu the operational problem is
they're going to overwhelm the IC use
that's all we're talking about you have
to take a deep breath we're not talking
about the Ebola virus here and you're
reflecting frankly the same level of
anxiety that people buy a larger
reflecting no don't panic don't shut
down everything and don't shut down the
operation that is responsible for
handling the situation
it just seems like you're giving us
contradictory information here in a
dance location no not in the building
no it's 50% of occupancy rate of this
building the occupancy rate of this
building would be in the thousands no
you said it's inconsistent with the
regulation I passed my regulation was
50% of rated occupancy for a room right
the Congress is up you want to close
down to Congress by your reasoning you'd
have to close the Congress you'd have to
close the Senate
you'd have to close the White House
you'd have to close all the federal
agencies well what's not essential that
we're talking about today you wanna pass
it early I say great as I said before it
doesn't go skinny fat
I would not rush an issue that we're not
ready to do right I don't want to pass
or sign a bad piece of legislation that
is not thought through so if there's a
complex issue that is not thought
through fine but the 99% of these issues
are fully thought through everybody
understands them it's yay or nay they
just don't want to say yea or nay
because they're controversial and the
difficult and the 50-50 issues of 6040
issues so they don't want to take a side
because then they're gonna take the
political heat from the other side but
on those issues say yea or nay I think
they should do their job yeah I think
they should do their job you should the
federal intervention what would this
look like and and and what what is the
goal with like the Corps and the Army
coming in so would they be taking state
buildings and converting those into
hospitals what what do you imagine that
looking like this is what they this I've
worked with the Army Corps of Engineers
when I was in at HUD and we actually
used them to build housing on Indian
reservations the Native American
reservations I have sunni dorms
come in take my sunni dorm retrofitted
for a medical facility and then I'll
contact medical schools and nursing
schools and I'll find extra access
people to come staff that SUNY dorm what
federal facilities do they have
available that we could now convert so
we have properties and buildings right
I have colleges I would do any of these
buildings I just don't have the physical
construction capacity to organize that
you know the government doesn't build my
government doesn't build right we
contract out everything and for us to
contract out you need a design you need
a plan you need an RFP and then you have
to be able to pay for it
the only government that builds is the
federal government you will ask dr.
Zucker what do you think the capacity
differential could be between the number
of ICU beds we have three thousand by
the which by the way 80% of occupied of
the current ICU beds so even if you are
beds to get some of the people out of
the ICU beds right because if 80 percent
are occupied of three thousand that
means we only have 600 beds we just said
how many are in ICU beds so far yeah but
how many did we say are in ICU beds 65
so we have 65 two day and we only have
600 yeah to the modeling that we're
working on to try to figure out the
spread of disease the period of time as
the governor mentioned about the issues
of flattening that curve that will help
us determine how many you need because
you don't want to have all of them at
one time if you flatten that curve
you can spread that over a period of
time and we have we have a team trying
to model that out and then I can answer
your question whatever I would say this
non-scientific based answer which I
would not rely on because I rely on the
good doctor in science my number you
need thousands you're going to be
thousands short thousands you cannot
purchase more ventilators we have
several thousand the ice cube beds have
the ventilators we have 3,000
ventilators you could use thousands
you will need thousands of more
ventilators arraignments have to happen
Child Protective Services have to happen
family court emergency orders has to
happen
non-essential motion practice motions
that you could hear later on civil
matters that you could hear later on
I'll leave that to the chief judge but
anything that is public safety is
essential
anything that is criminal justice is
essential but any matter that is not
time-sensitive
that is about money recoveries as
opposed to a more imminent need let the
chief judge make those decisions York
City
twenty-nine can you tell us about the
new death where was this individual at
County Hospital sure so there was one
individual who was elderly elderly
person that was identified yesterday who
had multiple medical conditions and
we're getting more information about
that but that person was in a New York
City Hospital we usually don't like to
give out the hospital names there well
there are three there are three deaths
that the governor mentioned to yesterday
and in the one today one of those was
also well the others were also with
medical many other medical conditions as
well three deaths total yes yesterday
and one today she died
today and she was admitted within the
past week indeed the exact date a few
no no so the reason that was different
was it was I wasn't identified until the
autopsy which is a different scenario
and that was the delay it was identified
in an autopsy and again these numbers
they're coming in now such frequency
depending when you have the person sit
down to make the chart by the time you
finish writing the chart the chart is no
longer accurate right so that's why you
get a little bit of a variance less
point I just want to stress the you need
1,000 mile
not science-based you will not be able
to flatten the curve to avoid the wave
you will be short
thousands of ICU beds thousands of
ventilators the only way to prevent that
today given this time constraint is to
deploy the Army Corps of Engineers and
use that capacity to retrofit existing
facilities to free up hospital beds a
decision is easy when you have no
options and here this nation has no
option
I sent the president a letter that is a
very rare occasion for me I said to the
president in the letter I offer these
suggestions as a governor as a former
cabinet secretary member as a person who
knows how the state government works and
how the federal government works this is
the state that has the highest number of
cases I said that the president in all
sincerity there's no place for Paula
I'm not playing politics I don't give a
darn
Democrat Republican whatever you are
this is about Americans protecting
Americans lives and I will work in full
partnership with the President on this
issue 100% but I asked him personally to
take this seriously I know it's a
dramatic action it may be an
unprecedented action this is a dramatic
time in an unprecedented time and great
challenges require great leaders and
great solutions and that's what this is
thank you very much